[Music]
hey guys the eighth and final season of
Game Jones premieres on April 14th
we don't know many details or should I
say spoilers about it
as given on security show me heightened
during filming for final season but at
least we know some in one of my recent
videos I brought you all the major
leagues and spoilers there be hundred
percent confirmed to happen in the final
season of gaming Jones epic battle for
me no fell in Episode three deny King
reigns Winterfell is on fire many died
ghost is back Jon Snow goes back to the
capital parley sweet Queen Cersei in
episode 4 and King's Landing is burned
down these are the four major events
that are confirmed to happen so if you
haven't seen those yet make sure to do
so in this video on the other hand I
bring you four more confirmed links and
spoilers about the eighth season and
even though this might not be major
events these are nonetheless quite
important let's start with a series of
reunions that will take place at
Winterfell in the season 8 premiere Jon
Snow made any with their entire crews
are currently heading north to prepare
for the Great War that it's coming even
sooner than expected
they're sailing towards white Harbor the
main seaport of the north with the
unsullied once they arrive over there
they will meet the Trekkie on the
kingsroad and then ride together to mean
FL of course all of this will take place
of screen and we'll only see all of them
together approaching Winterfell in the
very beginning of the first episode once
John arrives of NFL will have a
heartbreaking reunion with his family
wit's end sorry and brain as well as
with his friend Sam and his direwolf
ghost in fact it's been confirmed that
the opening scene will see the arrival
of John and Dane with their crew 7 FL
which is said to be similar to King
Robert's arrival in the series premiere
this episode will be an episode full of
reunions so we've been waiting for John
Terry night with Arya or for Arya to
reunite with the Hound or for almost
entire game appearance crew to be
together at the same place good news is
we'll finally get it in a very episode
of the final season beside many Iranians
premiere will also feature many times
first meetings between characters since
I said not to be thrilled that Jon
bananita Danny
but back turanians and right away on to
the most important reunion the one
between John and Arya we have been
waiting to see reunion between those
tools since the very first season we
have been hoping for John our union in
season
seven but it all had just missed the
chatter however it's finally happening
in the season 8 premiere john loves and
cares for all his siblings but john and
Arya have a unique bond John and I were
very close growing up it was John who
secretly had needle forged for Arya
encouraging her to become who she always
wanted to be Natalie did Westerosi
customs demanded in fact those two were
so close that in Georgia morons original
outline he had them marked as lovers
it's only fitting for them to see each
other again before the great world
begins and they will well it's easy to
say that John will be proud but also
blown away by how much R has grown as a
fighter it's also safe to say that aria
unlike sense I will support you on the
stage you know bending the knee to the
Dragon Queen in fact I think that Dany
and Aria will get along very well
considering how Danny likes from women
and Ari on the other hand also admire
strong women but admire dragons as well
the next conference spoiler takes place
in episode after it was revealed that
episode two will see the return of the
crypts of NFL which was being filmed on
its long-standing occasion as Shane's
Castle it was also reported they'll be
seen between two leading cast members in
crypts and they will be discussing Ned
Stark's death in this particular scene
so it's basically something similar to
what we already seen in season 7 and
since I know you're discussing its death
as well as the statue my guess is that
this time it'll be John and Danny
discussing it anyways the scene is also
said to and when they hear horn being
blown as in knowing the Nights Watch a
horn is blown to warn of someone
approaching eater Rangers returning
Wilding set agates or White Walkers
we're not sure what the horn means in
this scene but there's definitely song
approaching Winterfell
either enforcement's or White Walkers
another League gives us new characters
that we'll see in season 8 and the most
prominent one includes mark Richmond has
got a company commander Harris
Strickland fans who read The Dance the
Dragons may recognize the name of
homeland Sara Strickland the commander
of the golden company in the season
finale source revealed to Jamie that
Tyrion Greyjoy only pretended to be
heading back to Pike when he actually
sail to Essos to cardigan the company
and to bring them in his own fleet
Westeros to serve under her commands
this is not coming as a huge surprise
since in the fourth episode of the
season Cersei reeled her intentions to
take out a new loan from the iron bank
too hard on the company to expand their
armies this Elsword company is one of
the largest and most skilled mercenaries
consisting of 20,000 infantry cavalry
and war elephants with their help sir
she will take the advantage of the war
between the living and the dead I will
try to retrieve some things that as she
said belong to her those things that sir
she also revealed herself include the
lands the kingdoms that are currently
taken away from her all the golden
companies arrival at the capital in the
very beginning of season eight is not
coming as a huge surprise or surprised
at all this new character on the other
hand is many thought there will be no
room in season 8 for more characters
from George RR Martin's A Song of Ice
and Fire novels
and many theorize that would be Daria
naharis leading the golden company but
we were wrong we'll get a new character
Kerry Strickland in the book Strickland
is the current captain General de Gaulle
& Company and Lord of the exact how
Strickland from Westeros how Strickland
have been core members of the gun
company for four generations to its
founding in the aftermath of the
Blackfyre rebellion and surviving
Blackfyre supporters fled into exile in
the Free Cities among them was Harry's
great grandfather Harry was born in Zion
raised to serve in the Gullah Company as
were his father and grandfather before
him making him a four generation member
of the cell sir company which may
explain why he rose to such a high rank
despite his lack of martial prowess he
is not considered a very brave man and
many of his own captains think he's a
coward in many ways he is just a puppet
for the true leader of the golden
company one of his lieutenants called
Griff we'll see how much of that
characterization will make it to screen
the next spoiler is Rhaegar Targaryen
three appearance at some point of the
final season Jimmy Jones has a lot of
characters emit only six episodes life
that might not be enough to spotlight
all of them for example an Italian
married they are confirmed not to appear
in season 8
however Rhaegar Targaryen will come back
will scolding who played Rhaegar
Targaryen Dana's brother and John's
father in a flashback sequence in the
season 7 finale uploaded and then later
the picture himself outside the Europa
Hotel in Belfast during the filming of
the final season the world created by
george RR martin is large and takes
place in many different climates and
environments as such game occurrences
filming locations all over the world but
the principal location for filming the
Sirius is Northern Ireland Belfast this
is very many interior sets are shot as
well as the majority of exterior shots
lungs are short of the gammatron sector
in this case an actor that portrays
Rhaegar is staying above us it means
that he will appear in the up come
season as he's shooting some scenes in
Belfast also the fact that our gaming
sector starting this same hotel while
shooting is suggesting that we're eager
to garyun is most certainly coming back
for the final season now what does this
mean it probably means we'll get more
eager to gain in flashbacks although if
you're into some tin foil theories such
as Reger being alive or being someone
else there's hope for that as well all
we can say for certain is that Rhaegar
is back but it'll be most likely in a
flashback
after all George RR Martin's said we
will learn and see all the important
events that happen during Robert's
rebellion and that's why there will not
be the Robert's rebellion prequel George
our morning company stated that even
though they are currently working on
game trans prequels the Robert's
rebellion is most definitely not one of
them George explained that by the time
Song of Ice and Fire in by the time game
show is over we'll know every important
thing and we'll earn all cigarettes
about what happened during the rebellion
he then finishes by saying it'll feel
too much like a twice told tale this
basically means they'll get more
regularly Anna it maybe even Rhaegar
Robert flashbacks in the season 7 finale
bran upon being told that John is not a
bastard but rather illegitimate son of
Lena and Rhaegar Targaryen
he was his greensight I mean this is the
secret wedding for himself this
flashback is without a doubt the most
important flashback we've seen as far as
brain explain to Sammy to reveal that
Robert's rebellion was in fact built in
the why Rhaegar did not kidnap Liana she
loved him and he loved her their secret
marriage also means that Johnson of his
regards lawful son and rightful heir to
the Iron Throne
ahead of Rhaegar and her sister Danny so
which flashback can we expect to see in
the final season a few flashbacks that
will finally show us how Rhaegar and
Lyanna fell in love and why did they
decide to run away without leaving a
note to their families I would like to
see Rhaegar in brains flashback of a
tourney at Harrenhal which I'm almost
sure they will since i'm expecting from
the showrunners to explain to us how
Jon's parents fell in love and why they
decided to run away I'm expecting for
them to explain to us what was they
important for LeAnn and Rhaegar to leave
it out explanation to put the Seven
Kingdoms in the state of chaos to start
a rebellion prophecy perhaps many
believe that the entire tourney was in
fact organized by Crown Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen together the great lords of
Westeros and address the madness of his
father King Aerys the second Targaryen
entering moving from the unknown in more
simple words the great tourney at
Harrenhal is very tall started regularly
in a Mad Prince Rhaegar was champion of
the joust and in the end he chose the an
asterick
is the new queen of love and beauty
placing a crown of blooming two roses in
a lap this was very scandalous in that
not only was Rhaegar already married to
Ali of Dorne who was presented attorney
but Lian our cellphones picture to
Robert Baratheon was also present at
attorney it's basically a very tall
started beside Martin stamen there are a
few more clothes that are making the
greater need Harrenhal flashbacks even
more likely to come true and just take a
look on this shot published an official
game occurrence YouTube channel it's
been out for two years or so and it's
basically in the production tees if you
look closely on the shot you'll notice a
love shield will black bats all over it
the heraldry that consists of nine black
bats or a gold field is of house went
the very same house that hosted the
great tourney at Harrenhal
hanging the counter this shield has not
yet appeared that knowing that there is
only one season left
it's got appear in the final season and
no it's not possible for a soldier to
hold it in the current timeline because
house went is extinct and therefore it
can only appear in a flashback
anyway street raker being back for
season eight I think it's safe to say
that we can expect flashback or two at a
great tourney at Harrenhal that was the
beginning of a doomed love between kind
and noble Rhaegar and beautiful and
brave Liana of course a flashback of a
fight between Rhaegar and Robert would
also be great but it only six episodes
left is it really that important to the
story except that there's a major twist
regarding the battle say it wasn't
Rhaegar but someone else on the res
Armour that died instead of Rhaegar or
someone claiming himself to appear as
reg are using Ruby's I don't see why
also we need to see that fight yes I
would love to see it yes it would be
epic but unless he brings something to
the story I don't think they'll see it
in conclusion there are four main
confirmed events number one a series of
reunion SEF interval number two is seen
between two leading cast members in
crypts discussing Ned Stark's death the
scene ends with the horn being blown
number three a new character the most
prominent one a golden company commander
Harry Strickland number four Rhaegar is
back whether in a flashback or the
current timeline remains unknown these
four main events beside four major
events that are brought you a couple of
days ago are pretty much all the current
events regarding the final season and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace